Gerade ist in Kuba ein kleiner Meteorit niedergegangen.
Und es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass
die Einschläge sogar von größeren Asteroiden
zugenommen haben.
Das Leben auf der Erde ist in der jüngeren
Phase der Erdgeschichte deutlich risikoreicher
geworden.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Kanada hat nämlich
jetzt herausgefunden, dass das kosmische Bombardement
auf die Erde angestiegen ist!
Alles, was ihr zu diesem Thema wissen müsst,
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich spannende Wissenschafts-Videos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
kein Video. herzlich willkommen!
Dass Asteroiden auf die Erde treffen, ist
nichts Neues - unser Planet wurde seit seiner
Entstehung immer mal wieder von Asteroiden
getroffen und das wird wohl auch auch in Zukunft
wieder passieren.
Wir berichten regelmäßig über dieses Thema.
Denn ihr wisst alle: Asteroiden-Einschläge
sind eine reale Bedrohung für das Leben auf
der Erde.
Im Worst-Case können sie ein Massensterben
verursachen.
Bisher gingen Fachleute davon aus, dass die
Einschlagsrate im Laufe der Erdgeschichte
nach einem anfänglichen intensiven kosmischen
Bombardement auf einem niedrigeren Niveau
stabil gewesen ist.
Bei dieser Art von Forschung und der Ermittlung
der Einschlagsrate gibt es jedoch eine große
Herausforderung.
Und zwar sind auf unserem Planeten nur wenige
alte Krater erhalten.
Auf dem Mond gibt es eine andere Herausforderung:
Hier sind die entsprechenden Krater zwar noch
erhalten und auch gut konserviert.
Dennoch gestaltete sich die Bestimmung ihres
Alters bislang als ein äußerst kompliziertes
Unterfangen.
Doch ein Forschungsteam aus dem kanadischen
Toronto war jetzt erfolgreich: Ihnen gelang
es, insgesamt 111 Krater des Mondes zu datieren.
Als Hilfsmittel nutzten die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler dabei das Diviner-Instrument
der NASA-Sonde “Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter”
(LRO).
Damit ist es möglich, die Temperatur der
Mondoberfläche zu kartografieren und genau
das machte sich das Forschungsteam zunutze.
Sie analysierten, wie viel Wärme die Krater
nachts abstrahlen und konnten so indirekt
das Alter der Krater und somit auch die Einschlagsrate
bestimmen.
Der Trick dabei: Die Brocken auf dem Mond
zerfallen im Laufe der Zeit durch zwei Faktoren.
Zum einen durch sehr viele Mini-Einschläge
und zum anderen durch die großen Temperatur-Schwankungen
zwischen Tag und Nacht.
Dabei können kleinere Brocken deutlich weniger
Wärme speichern können als die größeren
Exemplare.
Die Wärmeabstrahlung der Krater gibt somit
also Aufschluss über das jeweilige Alter.
Die Ergebnisse überraschten sogar die Fachleute
selbst: Denn die Impaktrate des Mondes ist
demnach keineswegs stabil gewesen wie bislang
angenommen.
Stattdessen ist die Einschlagsrate vor rund
290 Millionen Jahren auffallend angestiegen.
Dieser Sprung in der Kurve lässt sich laut
der Autoren und Autorinnen auch auf die Einschlagsrate
von Asteroiden auf die Erde übertragen.
Diese Annahme konnte das kanadische Forschungsteam
auch belegen und zwar durch die Untersuchung
von irdischen Kratern.
Konkret analysierten sie sogenanntes Kimberlitvorkommen
- damit ist Gestein gemeint, dass bei urzeitlichen
Vulkanausbrüchen entstanden ist und das Krater
besonders gut konserviert.
Auch hier zeigte sich bei Untersuchungen,
dass es einen plötzlichen Anstieg des kosmischen
Bombardements ab der Zeit vor 290 Millionen
Jahren gab.
Der Faktor der Impaktrate in den letzten 290
Millionen Jahre ist damit um 2,6 höher als
in der Zeit davor.
Dazu die Wissenschaftlerin Sara Mazroue, die
an der Studie beteiligt war: „Unsere Studie
liefert Belege für eine dramatische Veränderung
in der Rate der Asteroideneinschläge auf
Mond und Erde, die sich etwa gegen Ende des
Erdaltertums ereignete”.
An dieses Ergebnis schließt sich eine super
spannende Frage an, auf die es bislang aber
noch keine gesicherte Antwort gibt.
Was genau führte zu dem plötzlichen Anstieg
des Bombardements?
Fachleute vermuten, dass es an Trümmern liegt,
die durch eine gewaltige Kollision im Asteroidengürtel
zwischen Jupiter und Mars entstanden sind
und noch bis heute ins innere Sonnensystem
katapultiert werden.
Sehr sehr spannend, was da wirklich passiert
ist.
Wir bleiben an dieser Story dran un halten
euch auf dem Laufenden.
Asteroid Mining, also bergbau auf Asteroiden
könne die Gefahr noch weiter erhöhen.
Alles dazu in diesem Video, auf jeden Fall
daufklicken: Asteroiden bedrohen die Erde
nach Asteroid Mining - Ansonsten: Bis dann,
belibt dran!